what's the apology that you're looking  for as a as a Jewish engineer I'm not  say as Lex let's not talk about you  being Jewish as Lex what's the apology  that you want me to say  to am I allowed to say Jewish tell me is  it anti-semitic for Yea to say Jewish  out loud no there's uh I don't like the  allowed that presumes censorship I think  you choose you have a powerful voice did  I prove did I did I prove that there was  censorship over the past two weeks who  censored you oh drink Champs who's oh my  Lord oh like Twitter and so on Twitter  that has less to do drink Champs that  hurt you the drink Champs uh that Noah  took it down took down your conversation  it didn't hurt you  man you got to be honest about this  we're still the kids we used to be  I put my hand on the stove to see if I  still bleed  and nothing hurts anymore I feel kind  free